la virée en fait ce sont des attaques
ddos qui sont effectués à partir des
milliers de pc en fait des pc de botton
appelle ça on peut essayer de récupérer
les adresses ip et sur certaines de ces
pays on peut essayer délocaliser il mort
ça provient de russie de france de
pologne ou n'importe quel peu importe le
pays les demandes de rançon pour les
gros pensez forcément de qui s'avère on
peut pas savoir de qui ça vient parce
qu'en général les demandes de rançon
vous devez effectuer notamment par
bitcoin est bientôt monnaie et c'est pas
traçables savons pas vous demander de
faire un virement sur un compte
professionnel et personnel oui on dit
d'ailleurs que les entreprises qui sont
à quai comme ça et qui à qui on fait un
chantage ont tout intérêt à payer parce
que de toute façon sinon ils peuvent pas
s'en dépêtrer est ce que c'est vrai ça
ils ont tout intérêt à payer après tout
dépend les éléments qui sont bloqués sur
leur pc est ce que ça vaut vraiment la
peine de payer ce que ça vaut vraiment
la peine par rapport aux montants qu'on
vous demande c'est à vous de juger ça
vous laisse juger par contre si vous
payez pas vous pouvez être sûr que vous
donnez voulait récupérer jamais et que
vous pouvez rien et c'est fou ça fait
vraiment cessé ses doses allant un peu
juste idriss pour revenir au cas de de
tpm pis pour vous hier donc pourquoi
donc des hackers se serait attaqué donc
à netflix canal+ ibérique amazon
whatsapp youtube wikipedia mais à
écouter en fait ce sont des grands
groupes qui ont quand même infligé des
sanctions à la russie alors peut-être
pas tous mais une grande partie d'entre
eux notamment netflix donc c'est
compréhensible que d'un point de vue du
gouvernement russe on se disent écoutez
nous on a des sanctions on perd de
l'argent à ce niveau là bas nous aussi
on va leur faire perdre de l'argent pour
vous les aurez aucun doute vous refaire
il ya peu de doute c'est une
cyberattaque écoutez franchement je ne
sais pas c'est ça ça paraît logique quoi
pour moi ya pas de hasard surtout dans
le contexte actuel n'y a pas de hasard
pourquoi ça tombe maintenant pourquoi ça
serait pas tombé ya six mois où il ya un
an ça pourrait être une réplique faite
aux anonymous parce que les anonymous
ont annoncé qu'ils allaient cyber
attaque et tout ce qui était alors
justement jalons ont parlé donc on a la
russie comme j'ai dis donc à 2
le groupe généreux ils ont une grosse
armada coeur ils sont très forts pour ça
on à l'ukraine qui sont pas fortes ont
fait un appel à des centaines de
milliers d'acteurs ça a fonctionné ces
anonymous vont les aider d'ailleurs
notre côté on a le monde entier donc le
monde sait quoi moi on va enlever
l'afrique on va parler de l'amérique
qu'ils ont dit simplement qu'ils
apporteraient un soutien à l'europe
c'est toutefois y avait une cyber
attaque au niveau de l'ukraine on a le
la france qui dit aussi qu'elle
apporterait un soutien l'ukraine 6 à une
cyberattaque on sait pas pour moi si ses
secrets il ya déjà eu d'intervention ou
pas et au milieu on a des anonymous est
un groupe qui est vraiment anonymes qui
n'a pas de leaders qui agit qui
interagit à travers le monde entier et
qui ont déjà fait des attaques sur 1000
5500 citrus ça notamment des sites du
kremlin décisions de banques des sites
gouvernementaux
on a vraiment un tas des sites
d'institutions n'a vraiment c'est quand
même un signal fort je trouve ça assez
fort c'est un signal fort sur les télés
c'est sort ce qu'ils ont compris ça et
ça va se poursuivre c'est vraiment que
le début là on est vraiment jeu des
arrières sa très forte et la guerre
cyber peut faire perdre vraiment un
million des centaines de millions voire
des milliards d'euros je veux dire
aujourd'hui anonymous attaque un groupe
pétrolier ou même vous c'est un média ça
peut faire perdre des centaines d euros
on en serait ce qu'un jour ça hein vous
bloquer un site petrossian d'une cyber
attaque économiquement c'est
catastrophique qui c'est catastrophique
enfin aujourd'hui vous si vous avez vous
subi c'est ce que vous avez subi hier
pendant une semaine elle est perdue la
chaîne le groupe c 8 va perdre une somme
d'argent c'est un long temps c'est vrai
tu le public passe on va être répercutée
par rapport à tout ce qu'ils ont rien
demandé donc voilà commercial e le les
anonymous ont bloqué à peu près 1500 6
pour certains d'entre eux ça a duré
quelques heures pour d'autres ça a duré
plusieurs jours donc ça des millions
d'euros de perte des sites pré taulier
des grands groupes et puis une riposte
de la russie directement après ils ont
bloqué un satellite en ukraine qui
permettent d mais qui permettait
d'émettre l'internet pour les ukrainiens
ce à quoi elon musk a répondu qui
mettait à leur disposition le satelis
starlink pour leur permettre d'accéder à
internet sannitz à télé star line qui
appartient au groupe space x ou y est
venu en aide aux ukrainiens est ce que
la puissance des racques heureuse et
sans limite je prends un exemple et ce
qui pourrait par exemple à quai une de
nos centrales nucléaires pour que nous
cessions des coupures ces énergies que
ça coûte encore plus cher qui est un
black out en france c'est sans limites
sans limite tout est possible tout est
probable après je pense qu'ils vont
quand même garder une certaine limite
ils vont pas aller jusqu'au bout d'un
black à total de l'europe vous savez
quand même que des câblages sous soit là
on a quand même parlé dans ces missions
je crois il ya quelques temps je pense
pas qu'ils prendraient 10 de tout couper
parce que eux aussi ça leur portrait
préjudice et prendrait le risque d'avoir
une réplique nucléaire d'un autre côté
donc il y la taxe nucléaire toutefois
sans que c'est des avertissements
internet aux européens et aux américains
il va y avoir une riposte derrière et ça
peut être en général que nucléaire parce
que grâce à ses lacets c'est peu quand
même à cette tragédie qui aiderait à
dire jean gallet xavier plus d'internet
vous avez plus dcri citée ya plus
distributeurs vous pouvez pu retirer
d'argent on rentre vraiment dans une
vieille et haut niveau au niveau des
banques aussi parce qu'il va se passer
au niveau des banques c'est très simple
si la plus d'internet les légers ab donc
les distributeurs ne fonctionne plus
vous pouvez plus retirés ou plus payer
votre alimentation peut plus vous
connecter au site de votre banque un
site de banque c'est très facile à
bloquer vous envoyer des milliers de
connexions par le biais d'une attaque
d'edo ce déni de service vous bloquer
les sites d'une banque plus de virement
plus d'argent pur andy
bloch et d'humanité c'est ça aussi bercé
sur la guerre mondiale comme il a raison
ce serait une guerre cyber pour moi il a
tout à fait raison